At Hogwarts, there are
four houses-- Gryffindor,
Hufflepuff, Ravenclaw,
and Slytherin.
The bar chart below shows
the number of house points
that each house received today.
How many house points
did Hufflepuff receive?
So if we look at
this bar chart, we
could assume that this column
right over here is Hufflepuff,
because it's the
only one that starts
with an H. This will be
Gryffindor, this is Ravenclaw,
and this must be Slytherin.
And so, if we look
at Hufflepuff's bar,
it looks like they have
3 points scored today.
So let's put 3 points.
All right, let's try one more.
So here they're saying,
how many house points
did Slytherin receive?
So this is going
to be Slytherin,
and it looks like they
received 4 points.